gay guys get buffed real good yeah you
think it's because their ability to
squat is real good I think so I think
and I mean spot you know what I mean oh
yeah but right like there's no like
there's no failing PRS
[Music]
all right all right we gotta say rest in
peace to Mr Justin Vicky
he's an american-born Indonesian career
bodybuilder oh bro this video three oh I
love this yeah oh that's him what's that
like 400 pounds or something 405. so
what happened in case you haven't seen
it uh here's the video of it happening
we don't have to you know obviously put
this up but in case this is what I need
to see at the time oh is that when you
do what is it called back squats yeah
just yeah back squats
so he's got his Spotter and the spotter
couldn't hold it with him and then oh
buddy oh buddy what happened he just
fell so what happened is he he it broke
his neck oh my God so it happened right
then and there no he didn't die here I
think a lot of people oh my God where he
like passed away but what happened is he
fell unconscious from uh breaking his
neck and there was pressure on some
vital nerves with the barbell yeah at
the time that it happened so it made
like a a pressure to some nerves
connected to his heart and lungs and
they needed to rush him to surgery so
that happened on July 15. on July 16 he
actually
um like video called his mom and told
him what happened oh cool his uh mom
came with his son and his ex-wife to
visit him he went into surgery after the
surgery he slipped into a coma and
passed away July 17. so two days after
that oh my God have they talked to the
splatter yet
he wasn't spotting pretty good huh so
when you watch that like as as like you
know
people that are you feel like it's the
spotter's fault how do you spot 400
pounds would you invite the spotter to
the funeral because then he have two
guys on each side right he had two guys
on each side and then one guy behind him
I think it's hard to say because
um splatter drops the casket and where
was those bars bro what about those bars
that you have on the side so the
spotters which is the the actual safety
bars they are there but it's so low
that's why he's not crushed by it but
man it's like it's so it takes a team is
everything that's happening here like to
standard that's like yeah that's good
let me see you can press press play it
looks like y'all should change the
standard like what what exactly could
have but not all spotters are created
equally so yeah he's he's spotting
correctly he's going down with them yeah
I spot him correctly
well how did it get to his neck like
wait what the [__] wait is there a
safety bars no that's not safety I told
you the things on the left dude off the
so there's a lot of things that went
wrong if I had to brainstorm one is it
doesn't it doesn't have the saw the
safety spotters which are the metal bars
on the side the second thing is
um I wasn't there for the whole workout
session so usually if you're trying to
work up to a Max
you guys kind of have like a dynamic and
you kind of like have audibles back and
forth I think maybe 10 more pounds 15
pounds I feel good how do you feel
whatever I thought but I was like the
second thing is I wasn't there
I thought he knew something yeah
so like you would talk you would like
talk back and forth because then there's
like some sort of trust yeah yeah yeah
usually you trust the spotter the most
because they're they're seeing new move
but then they would also bounce back how
do you feel oh that was my knee shifted
I think that's when I got it so there's
like a lot of things that can go into
what happened but that is very routine
actually where people do like you know
because sometimes at commercial gyms
you'll see a guy be like hey can you
spot me real quick and you don't know
who this [__] guy is you don't know
how well he knows how to spot you don't
know how well or how like if he's ever
spotted before so I think that could
have that's when I heard about the story
I thought in my head I was like that's
probably what happened he probably just
asked some guys randomly to spot them
and they just some people they they pull
too quick and you're like I was I had it
yeah and sometimes the spotter might
have gotten in his way yeah so like
there's three main streets yeah there's
three main sports that squat there's
Olympic weightlifting there's power
lifting and there's also bodybuilding
Olympic weightlifters they're used to
squatting on their own and if they can't
make the weight they'll dump it right
behind them the problem is maybe he that
that would have been a choice but he
might have been thinking about a spot or
anyone doesn't want to dump the weight
on the spotter so he might have just
been like oh being selfless about it you
know
so it's like there's a lot of things but
then would a spotter know that the
weight is going to be dumped in their
Direction they would not know because
when you're spotting the minute you have
a spotter like both of you guys are
committed to getting the weight up
together when something bad happens
that's the understanding okay but then
so it's because of that he doesn't he
you kind of rule out that technique of
let me just dump the weight like I
dumped the weight uh behind me many
times because I don't have a spotter and
I know that's my way of getting out but
if I have a spotter I would never dump
the weight because it will hurt the
person behind me in a situation where
you know you can't hold it up and the
spotter also doesn't seem to have
because it looked like it went you just
throw it Forward what do you know
you kind of both have to just come down
together and kind of like talk it
through what you're going to do because
for him it went up and then it rolled
over his neck it rolled over is not
gonna
do you why that much weight is there
like it seems like he couldn't handle
that he's trying to PR yeah he might
have been trying to hit PR see if he's
stronger than before yeah when you're at
that point where you're trying to hit
your PR does is that like
in most cases is that like okay now we
have to really be extra [__] careful
or is it yeah it should be depending not
all people train like that though right
like some people are a little reckless
with how much weight they put on at a
time like you just it's a mixed bag I
feel like sometimes do we know because
we can't hear anything there's no sound
but do we know that the his spot is not
like telling a [__] joke in his ear
or something and he's joking and he's
laughing he's like you feel my dick you
feel my [__] dick he gets here but
yeah
stop playing stop playing
that's probably what happened but I
would [__] up your strength for sure if
you're laughing a little bit but there's
tons of videos online of people just
[__] up spotting all the time like
it's very common do you think if he
docked his dick actually inside it would
have been more support more stable yeah
if they both only Bart would know such a
good point yeah probably I've never
tried that Bart told me he clenches his
butthole yeah when he when he squats at
the top though when bark squads his
barbell shorts are getting eaten up yeah
they they sink in pretty good all the
way it looks like you kind of are able
to joke around when you're working out
not if I'm pushing like people you never
had a spotter to like do a little bit in
your ear real quick dude when someone's
hitting the pr at barwell Brigade like
the whole vibe changes of everybody
around everyone's just like honed in so
that's awesome at a commercial gym
everyone's on a different page some
person I'm just here for general fitness
you have another guy who's like a
professional bodybuilder so he's
training like this is his job there's
another person that's like oh that's my
New Year's resolution doing it for the
first time so that's why the commercial
gym atmosphere is kind of crazy because
it's like having a NASCAR driver or
someone getting a driver's permit having
you know like a soccer mom all sharing
the same parking lot yeah versus a place
like barbell everyone is generally on
the same page so the minute someone is
about to hit a PR like uh if people can
see they'll like they'll be side spots
more spotters will come that's what I
was wondering like if you're gonna hit a
weight you've never really hit yeah
would is it normal to call extra people
hey can we get but and at a gym where
everyone's on the same page people will
just volunteer their Community yeah but
I feel like parvo Brigade is a different
Community I feel like I'll watch videos
of Marvel again it's like when
somebody's hitting a PR they're like
[__] taking chocolate like LeBron
throwing that chocolate yeah yeah take a
snap sucking that you know what I mean
everybody's like breathing heavy like
it's an intense Community that's like
I'm about to do something but that's not
like man has never done before it wasn't
really my experience at barbell were
good when I was trying to hit a PR most
people were loling
I just had a different experience I
guess yeah at the same time a lot of
people that uh because commercial gyms
are so convenient there are a lot of
people when they are going to hit
specific lifts they'll go to a specific
gym so there's bodybuilders is that all
just for specifically personal gyms
because there's AC it's nice you can go
to the sauna after but like let's say
they are going to hit a big lift or
something they might go with their
training Partners to this specific gym
because they have this equipment oh
because he was in Bali right yeah and it
was I guess like a bali it might have
been a commercial gym I'm not sure I'm
sure I'm assuming well where are the
[__] metal side spot [__] thing
yeah that's the biggest thing and
sometimes freak accidents just happen to
so that could have been something he's
been hitting six months straight right
and he just never thought this was gonna
happen
which is this is crazy did it look like
his legs like like it just failed no it
look it actually looked like he was in
control even on the way down it just
looked like the passing of the weight or
whatever was like a freak accident at
the bottom but that angle right like the
way the spotters behind him how could he
ever pick that up like how could you
hope to see yeah they're supposed to do
is if the bar stays on them you spot
them through his arms so you keep him in
his form and in his structural rigidity
you keep it you keep it that way he
didn't do that at all he was reaching
over his shoulders I don't know he's on
the bar oh he's holding the bar no you
don't want all the bars you don't want
to set you don't want to separate the
bar from those yeah
then if it rolls especially with that
much weight if it rolls too high yeah
then [__] like that because the lifter
is bracing as hard as they can and then
so you don't want to unbrace them you
know what I mean like they're like 100
tight so you want to keep that at that
region and essentially like you're
attached to the barbell yeah he's not
squared up to it at all he's holding the
barbell this is like I told you
should have been [__] to butt yeah
shipping right up there docking it
you gotta dock that extra support damn
that's really unfortunate that's so sad
though man it is man doesn't that make
you not want to squat ever again do you
think this is why I don't know I might
be reaching out a limb here but like you
know like
a lot of gay guys get buffed real good
yeah do you think it's because their
ability to squat is real good I think so
I think and I mean it's spot you know
what I mean oh yeah the butt right like
there's no like there's no failing PRS
yeah over there I'm saying and you're
powered by love yeah yeah there's no
shame about it either yeah that's what I
was saying because when I'm spotted like
I'm I I avoid pring because I don't want
the guy behind me to [__] do this and
then the whispers in your ears it's not
funny it's like it's like that's why
they asked that's why the Spartans were
all gay with each other because they had
to win wars together yep it's like
you're fighting for nothing just your
brother but your lover is that why
bartzella are you maybe I'm a little bit
gay I'm just doing the math here and
Asians are good at math so I'm just
throwing that out there
they're fetishizing my race and are you
we were fetishizing your abs at lunch
I'll say that
[Music]